if there's anything that will make you
sound guilty of something it's talking
about the fact that you're sure you
could pardon yourself and that's the
latest in this sort of growing comedy of
errors that is the Donald Trump
presidency we learned over the weekend
that Donald Trump has been talking more
and more with his lawyers about who he
could pardon could he pardon himself his
children his associate and as usual
defenders of Trump called the reports
about this fake news Trump aids denied
it and then Donald Trump started
tweeting about pardons himself yet
another instance were trump de facto
confirms the stories that are being
called fake news by his defenders and
aides Donald Trump took to Twitter to
talk about pardoning and he says he has
all the power when it comes to pardoning
tweeting over the weekend while all
agree the US president has the complete
power to pardon why think of that when
only crime so far is leaks against us
fake news now the simple explanation of
this is he was just commenting for a
friend he just meant yeah he could
pardon but this is these are not
questions for anything he's thinking
about doing it's something thinking
about doing for friends why think of
pardons he says well clearly he's
thinking about them since he's tweeting
about pardons at 7:00 a.m. in the
morning on a weekend when you start
talking about pardons you don't exactly
project innocence and the timing seems
to be related to Robert Miller now
expanding the investigation into Donald
Trump's personal finances and business
dealings Trump issued this sort of red
line statement last week during his
interview with the New York Times where
he was asked if Muller starts Luke
looking into your personal business
finances blah blah blah would that cross
a red line and Trump said yeah I think
it would and that seems to have struck a
nerve with Donald Trump and panicked him
because that's exactly what Robert
Muller is into is looking into right now
and not only is Donald Trump talking
about pardons Trump team Pat is now
looking into how they might undermine
Robert Muller and cast doubt about
credibility again if you've done nothing
wrong you publicly cooperate with
investigation so that they'll end and
you can move on when you start doing
opposition research on a prosecutor
things are not going well for you I
don't think that it's too big of a
surprise that he's talking about pardons
and maybe even firing the special
prosecutor given the fact that he's
fired the previous guy investigating him
and also if you look at the timing of
all of this I mean this week his son his
son-in-law is former campaign manager
are all scheduled to testify to Congress
I mean you'd have to imagine that
damning information could come out of
that that he would meet part of them for
no doubt about it and the bigger picture
that's being paid to do here is pretty
obvious and asked about pardons the
White House didn't rule out the
president was considering pardons in the
Russia investigation here is Sarah
Huckabee Sanders be new and we'll talk
about this later as well White House
press secretary right I believe she was
named replacing Sean Spicer take a
listen to this can you clarify where the
president stand on the issue of pardons
is he considering pardons figures in the
Russian investigation is does the
president commute that he has the power
to party so look at refer you to the
comments that have already been made by
the outside counsel in terms of their
actions the president maintains pardon
powers like any president would but
there are no announcements or planned
announcements on that front whatsoever
for themselves the power Department so
like I said I don't have anything to add
beyond what the outside counsel is
already stated on that six months in
folks this is where we are and in case
you care about the specifics it's not
actually clear if the president can
pardoned himself it's what we might
describe as untested legal waters and
I'm not going to dive in more deeply to
that there's a lot that's been written
about whether the president could pardon
pardon themselves for me the story right
now is not about whether Trump could
pardon himself he can't pardon himself
from impeachment and that is a very
specific knowledge that we have the real
issue is if you believe yourself and
your associates to be innocent you don't
go on social media and proclaim that you
can pardon people that is what's called
panic and if Donald Trump and his
associates are innocent they're the
biggest fools on the planet at this
point Pat because innocent people
constantly lie
about meetings with Russia stupidly
hiding so many different contacts if
they didn't do anything wrong then all
of this lying and and obfuscation makes
no sense at all
and take a good look at that response by
Sarah Huckabee Sanders a new White House
press secretary because even though
she's a lot more tailored and OnPoint
than Sean Spicer ever was we're
certainly going to get a lot less
information out of her oh yeah no doubt
about it and that also is something I
want to talk about what we can expect on
with Anthony Sierra Moochie directing
White House the White House
communications which was more of the
major news over the weekend the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership